labour's been warning of mass
unemployment calling for a back to work
budget so this week you must be
very pleased by what we've seen lots of
focus uh
on jobs uh in russia sunac's statement
and boris johnson's saying we should be
going back to work if we can well i'm
afraid i think
the summer statement this week was a
real missed opportunity
possibly the last opportunity we've had
to
save tens of thousands if not hundreds
of thousands of jobs over the coming
months with some
very poorly targeted and badly designed
uh schemes which and just not up to the
task
of saving all those jobs especially
in some of the key sectors most
adversely
affected by this crisis and i think
we've gone
from a government saying it will do
whatever it takes to russia sunak saying
on wednesday
he would do whatever he can and in
between that rhetoric
will fall at many businesses many jobs
and some key sectors will fall between
the gap of whatever it takes and
whatever it can
so the government really do need to do
more i think and i think there's some
ideology getting in the way here now
uh why they won't support key sectors uh
that they said
that they would uh you know they seem to
have this aversion to what they might
call picking winners but instead what
they're doing
is i'm afraid creating losers and i
think ideology is getting in the way
of them really taking quite a creative
approach to the furlough scheme
so that we can really support and retain
and protect
jobs over these coming weeks and months
at the same time though
isn't the reality that the government
won't be able to save every job or save
every business this is an unprecedented
challenge
the furlough scheme has been an
unprecedented
response to that challenge and of course
at some point it does need to be
wound down you're talking about more
targeting as well but surely
the government needs to get things out
as quickly as possible rather than doing
things
that could be more complicated and
frankly take more time to do
well yes they they do need to do that
but they really could have
focused you know these large sums of
money that they were talking about on on
wednesday
where they were needed most you know is
the uh
nine billion pound furlough bonus or the
three and a half billion pound
uh stamp duty relief is that going to
save
the tens of thousands of jobs in the
aerospace
aviation uh automotive sectors that
really received
nothing at all on wednesday falling far
short of their own
expectations what is that going to do to
support
a hospitality sector really that really
still needs it even though it's now
parts of it have now reopened they're
operating at less than 50 percent of
capacity
and are likely to for for many months
ahead
so we could have seen i think more
creativity
and much more targeting and better use
of some of the funds uh that they
identified
and and of course you know maybe not
every business and
every job uh can be saved but let's
just remember that every business that
goes bust
in this crisis every job that is lost
uh because of this crisis that were
previously viable businesses previously
decent good jobs as as few weeks ago as
february
every single one of those will really
deepen
and lengthen that recession and will
take a long time for this country to
to come back okay i am going to have to
come in just because that's a few things
that i do want to
get across in the interview without
running out of time um
one of the big parts of trying to reopen
particularly the hospitality industry is
to convince people that it's safe
to go shopping safe to go to restaurants
and bars and of course
face coverings uh could be a big part of
that
do you think that face covering should
be mandatory in shops as they are in
scotland
and was it a good example to set last
week when euan kirstama
went to a bar in london without wearing
face masks yourselves well i think we
need real clarity on this issue now from
the government
once again wouldn't it be helpful to
actually wear the face coverings
well yes and we we followed the um the
guidance that is the guidance
in brewdog where we were on monday
obviously in bars
and restaurants it's not mandatory to
wear
face masks so that you can eat and drink
and be in
in those locations was it a mistake to
not wear one though but it wasn't
it wasn't what the requirement was of us
uh going into
to that venue but i do agree with you
that we do need to get a lot more
confidence back in the system
and if uh mandatory wearing of face
masks in shops
will help to do that then we absolutely
support it and we think the government
instead of just kind of showing a bit of
leg occasionally on these things by
briefing newspapers or
or saying things uh that are not clear
guidance
in in press conferences as the prime
minister did on friday you know get some
clarity that's the sort of thing that
will really
get confidence back in into the system
and get people feeling
that they can go to the shops they can
go to restaurants they can go to bars
so you support the idea of mandatory
face masks even though you didn't wear
one yourself
well i i would support the fact the
mandatory abs
absolutely and that i think is for shops
i think obviously in bars and
restaurants
there are different issues there because
if you're in a bar in a restaurant you
are
eating food you are drinking uh and and
so on so it's
that's why the guidance is is different
at the moment in bars and restaurants
okay now i'm interested to talk to you a
little bit about
women and the particular impact that the
lockdown and the economic hit
of coronavirus might have on women who
predominantly work
in a lot of the sectors that are most
impacted things like hospitality for
example and the beauty industries
and also if you look at for example
research from the ifs that suggests that
working mothers
uh mothers one and a half times more
likely than fathers to have been lost
their job or quits and slot down began
more likely to have been furloughed in
lockdown mothers
combined work and child care in 47 of
their working hours
compared to 30 percent with fathers are
you worried that lockdown is going to
send us back to the 1950s
i'm really worried about the
implications of
of this crisis on women in particular
also those of black and ethnic minority
backgrounds too
a woman under the age of 25 is six times
more likely to be in a job at risk as a
result of coronavirus than
than a man over the age of 25 and
somebody whose black and ethnic minority
background is twice as likely so there
are real
implications here the care the child
care sector
is in massive distress as you say
women are much more likely to be working
in some of the sectors that
haven't yet been allowed to reopen or
reopen fully so
beauty was much later than pubs and
restaurants i mean i fully support pubs
and restaurants but
we need to look at beauty as well and
now they can only partially
reopen um the events and wedding sector
still in complete lockdown these
disproportionately employ
people uh young women and
disproportionately employ people of
black and ethnic minority backgrounds so
i think we need a proper strategic
approach here
to how we are going to support uh
different types of people in different
parts of the country
both to protect them in the jobs that
they're in but also how they could
get into new work now kirsten has been
leader of labour for 100 days um i might
be at fault here but i can't think of a
single
policy that he's announced in that time
can you help me out
well i don't think now is the time for
manifesto commitments especially not
because of the
context that we're in you know we're in
an unprecedented
public health and economic crisis with
things i mean no one's expecting
unbelievably quickly
no one's expecting a manifesto that's
far away from the election but
what i'm a little bit uh confused about
is the lack of policies any politics
is the only policy that kirsten has that
he isn't jeremy corbyn
no i don't think that's fair at all i
think he's got off to a fantastic start
as leader i think in your first 100 days
as leader of the opposition fresh out of
a general election
to have made such an impact on
the public the public really like him
they've got to know him they like what
he's
about they like the way he's been
challenging the government where
necessary but being constructive
uh with the government where that's not
necessary and i think you know he's
really
begun to make his mark on the labour
party and to do but not a single policy
well no that's not true i think we've
been clear that we've
we've got differences with the
government there are things that we
would have done differently for example
on the economic crisis we would have a
much more flexible approach to
the furlough we would extend the
furlough scheme we would be doing a lot
more now today
to protect the jobs of today with real
support for key sectors
like aerospace like automotive like
hospitality
than the government are willing and able
to do
and we would uh spend some of that money
more wisely as well
okay now just to finish one area that i
am a little bit confused on
policy-wise is whether or not labour is
considering a wealth tax or an asset tax
so first kierstama said the government
should look at wealth taxes the shadow
chancellor
annelise dodd said we need a new
settlement then this week she said
labour wasn't calling for higher taxes
and then just in case you weren't
confused enough already
dan carden the shadow treasury minister
then said
that reports labour were ditching plans
for a wealth tax were false so
can you please help me out here what is
actually going on well look we we're a
long way off
um these kind of conversations and that
is because
we don't know what the state of the the
public finances
are going to be and indeed the
government don't know that either
rishi sunak agreed with with us
this week when he said that the real uh
big indicator of any whole
or any size and shape of hole in the
public finances
in the coming months is whether we can
protect jobs and employment today
because
mass redundancies mass job losses will
have a
devastating impact not just for those
individuals
but on the public finances with less
taxes coming in
and more money going out in terms of
benefits and so on so
we can really shape what is going to be
necessary
for the future of any tax and spending
policy today
by protecting and creating jobs today
and that is our focus
that is what we we want to see we want
to see a vibrant
healthy economy that is growing with
people in work
and that is the best way to protect okay
thank you